i mentioned at the top of the show uh
that i needed to
um verify this fact and uh who better to
help me verify this fact than the host
of the jump on espn reporting from the
nba bubble
uh where the lakers just uh dismantled
the now banged up heat in game one uh
the host of uh
espn's jump and again reporting from the
nba finals rachel nichols how are you
rachel
hello my friend how are you i am well is
is there is there
uh a rule where one win can equal four
and wrap up in nba finals is there such
a thing i did i don't know i just
want you to describe the last meal you
had for me that was not
served in a cardboard and plastic box so
i can move vicariously through you
okay very good uh okay
what would i i'd happen to have
yesterday well what what i have
yesterday oh i had dom's
uh dom's meatballs um you know i
um i i put some broccoli in it chopped
up a little bit of garlic put it all
together in a red sauce
uh is that does that make does that piss
you off that's right that pretty much
does it for me we um one of our
colleagues cassidy hubbard was nice
enough
to send us some chicago style pizza down
here because pizza in particular the two
things that are very hard to get in the
nba bubble
are pizza and sushi which you know
i mean look we can all live without that
in our life for a period of time but
there's only so far i can go without
pizza
so cassidy was nice enough to send some
chicago pizza down
we were excited and then it turned into
a like four day odyssey
of getting permission for the hotel to
heat up a quote for an
object in their in their kitchen and so
it had to be the pizza had to be sent to
a different
less sterile hotel because until the
pizza was cooked
it was not considered sterile then once
it was in the oven
it was sterile but not where we were so
then it had to get
get driven back to where we were and i
got to tell you that whole 30 minutes or
less thing
that does not apply in the bubble okay
and then we wanted a knife or a pizza
cutter to cut the pizza
also not considered sterile sorry you're
on your own
so that's kind of our situation here
much more importantly everyone else's
health everyone is healthy i have to
lose track of that
but i do really like pizza rich so it's
tough so rachel i understand the
conundrum here
um that that uh that that you've you've
been down there
and it does keep everyone safe but you
gotta you
you do have to take solace in the fact
that there
is some sort of pizza reheating protocol
that uh nobody ever really thought of
no stone left uncharacteristic
and then the sushi i mean i guess you
don't want to uh make sushi out of
whatever tuna is in the man-made lake
there by uh by one of those hotels
dory and there's also a sort of tuna a
sushi
florida sitting outside like if it has
to go through like six stages there's a
point where you don't want it
plus i guess wait for it here i'm not
done hold on
the dory roll right isn't that what it
would be down there in in
in disney world the dory roll that i'm
sure
isn't that mean i guess yeah
you can't have a dory cut roll that's
terrible for the children
although every disney movie rachel the
parents die in it
anyway okay trust me i know that you i'm
sure susie started but like
like especially the mother come on yeah
i mean
honestly even in frozen hatred of
mothers even in frozen they go down with
the ship like what's going on here
yeah in later disney movies they seem to
be killing both parents which i guess
has like some solace but you know
i don't know rachel nichols here on the
rich eisen show
okay um so where were we again the nba
finals
that's what we call a reset um
what to make of uh what's what can you
tell us about the injured heat players
because
uh if if if there's no uh dragach
there's no
uh autobio that would be uh essentially
a wrap one would assume what do you mean
yeah
i i think so so look we don't have an
update yet the heat haven't come to to
speak at media availability yet
um you know i saw goron limping uh
you know back into the locker room after
going to get some medical treatment in a
different room last night
it didn't look good now that being said
he did try to come out for the second
half
and play and only got like halfway down
the hallway and a doctor
medical person from the heat stopped him
and and you know
in an admirable way i think all of these
players
they're so dedicated in general and the
heat team in particular
the mindset is i don't care i'm getting
back out on the court but there's a
point the body just won't let you
so the reporting is that that goron has
a planner to shed his tear
that's normally a six-week injury i
don't know
i don't know how they would get him back
up although it has happened in playoff
history there have been
you know take a shot and get back out
there it's just sort of i don't know how
effective he would be or if that
could cause any further damage because
i'm not a doctor um
and then with bam it's his shoulder
they're calling it a shoulder strain and
it's just important
even in my non-medical training to i
know to always remember that strain by
definition is a slight care of the
muscle like that's what a strain is
now hair sounds dramatic which is why
they call it a strain
but it is like a little bit of a tear of
the muscle so i just don't know how much
little that is and and what that means
for him playing or not
no obviously we need these guys healthy
we meaning
you know everyone who is rooting for for
a competitive series right i mean even
if you're a laker fan well i don't know
maybe for like a fan you want them to
win in four and that's it but like
i just think look it's the nba finals
the games in the bubble have been so
good
like the basketball has been so good and
heat lakers was a tantalizing matchup
and you'd like to see them
actually match up no matter who wins and
and also you know
uh i was hoping and again that this
could be jimmy butler's moment
and i know through years of covering
jimmy butler if i'm not mistaken rachel
after he after he blowed up the uh
the practice in minnesota i don't know
what you're talking about recycling you
were you were
you you got an exclusive interview with
him almost literally five minutes later
um so this is his moment right this is
what he's been building for
towards forever is this yeah i mean it's
a little bit of a referendum too
on on how he operates and the way you
know that that
he had coaches or front office people in
several cities who
felt like oh you know he's bad for team
chemistry or he's bad for coaches or
he's bad in the locker room
and really win or lose in the finals i
think it's been kind of proven that with
jimmy it's more a matter of fit
and the way that he and the heat have
been saying is like hey we're not for
everyone
and i think that that's always an
important thing to remember in sports
that there's you know i
kind of always say 10 10 percent like 10
of the players could play anywhere and
be amazing and 10 percent of players
can play anywhere and probably be pretty
terrible and always be almost about to
get cut
but those 80 in the middle whatever
sport you're talking about
fit is so important what are the other
pieces
around that player how do they fit in
with the coach and the system and the
front office and the way
the the cycle of the team in that moment
and all of that stuff and
jimmy is a prime example of fit and as
he and the heat have pointed out
you know he says i'm not for everyone
but i'm for this team and and that's
certainly certainly true and the miami
heat is an organization aren't for
everyone
you know dan waders is in this series
with the lakers uh it didn't turn out
that the heat were for him
um but when there is a mass it's pretty
cool to watch and we have seen win or
lose we have seen that with jimmy butler
in the heat
rachel nichols host of espn's the jump
and reporting from the nba finals in the
bubble right here on the rich eisen show
not to
not to pry and not to tell you how to
you know your show should do its
business
no no no that's all good uh i i i don't
want to tell you the last time i had
pizza you'd be very upset
um so um
i'm assuming uh the jump on its rundown
in between games one and two of this
finals
might have kyrie's latest statement on
uh on
on how he uh feels comfortable deferring
to a teammate he's yet to play with
except in an all-star game um and how
quote this is the first time in my
career i can look down and be
like that mfer um can make that shot too
and i'm trying to recall his who his
past teammates are that he might have
had a crunch time moment with
yeah how does this is this on your
rundown rachel
with lebron i mean by the way it's it's
not just
the kyrie comment about that i i assume
it's from the same podcast
um that there was a quote i saw where it
says
uh kyrie said i don't really see us
having a head coach
kd could be a head coach i could be a
head coach someday
jacques vaughn could be a head coach
could do it one day it's a collaborative
effort oh boy
now he also in that same podcast praised
steve nash pretty heavily
so i do think that i will say this i
think with kyrie in particular
um you know by the way sorry that last
quote about
jack vaughn is attributed to kd not
kyrie but but with kate with kyrie in
particular
you really do have to take the hole that
if you take one or two things he says
i'm not saying he shouldn't be
responsible for everything he says
because he said it he's an adult
he's certainly been in this legal time
now he knows how this works um
but i will say that often when
you read a pull out quote from something
if you then kind of listen to the whole
thing there is more context
so this did just cross my radar but i
had a very important radio show
to come do so i have not done the entire
listening of the entire podcast yet
i believe it was just released this
morning um and so
uh we'll we'll see as we listen as we
get get toward the jump we will
certainly be hitting it and exactly what
and how
we'll find out on national television
this afternoon but uh i look forward to
that you chopping that up
so no it's going to be great um
now look rachel uh if you can i don't
have the direct line to kyrie that i'm
sure you do
okay so so but uh i did
there's just two cents i want to offer
here uh being from staten island new
york born and raised in staten island
new york
uh and i know kyrie knows the area very
well because i
i heard him talk about how he always
wanted to be a net
from his from his new jersey net
love days that i've honestly he and the
next person i meet will talk about that
i guess so all he's got to do
all he's got to do in this market with
the knicks being as down as they are all
he's got to do
is just show up and play basketball and
not say stuff like this
that's it and win and win
and everyone will flock to brooklyn that
the hot mess
is the owner in new york let him be the
hot mess
don't what are we doing what are we
doing i mean rachel
essentially the carrie carrier being
experienced rich
life is better with more more color in
it we're more hungry
you know the nba the nba uh rob perez
who goes under the twitter handle
worldwide wise yeah
he's very popular on nba twitter has a
great sort of recurring
uh picture he throws up where it's like
a workplace sign
and uh you know it's it's like zero days
without unnecessary drama
and like you're supposed to write in how
many days like zero days without a
workplace accident and it's always zero
days without unnecessary drama and like
that's the nba man
i wouldn't have it any other way oh
man who's the most difficult one on your
set to corral
uh i'm i've done this for a a living
with a bunch of
very prideful nfl players you've got
you've got you've got some been there
done that uh uh high personality
individuals
what about for you rachel let's be
honest here um well
i mean again you can you can draw from
the comments i just made about kyrie in
the nba that i like
a little like unstable drama me too i've
got michael irvin michael irvin spoke at
my daughter's baby naming rachel he was
at my wedding susie invited him he
showed up in an electric blue tuxedo i
love the guy but he's a handful
so for me i actually seek those players
out to be on the job because i
those are some of the players i love
covering the most and and i do
it's a sport right like let's all
there's god knows there's a lot more
serious things going on in the world
right now like let's let's not take our
basketball or football or anything else
so seriously
um so you know whether it's on my show
it's kendrick perkins or richard
jefferson
um they're both dead on and great if you
say we got to talk about this they will
absolutely do it right
but the the cat the one catch is if
there's something they do want to talk
about
and a producer and this is richard in
particular because he's such a like
troll when it comes to this kind of
stuff and it's a great sense of humor
um if the producer says oh well let's
not talk about that because it'll be too
much of a diversion you know we go
take that sideways we won't have time
for the next topic that is pretty much
like a bright green light for richard
but what he needs to do is talk about
that thing and throw the segment
off time in life and by the way i do
want i want to say this again i said at
the beginning i'm going to say it again
like total pro like do not like kyrie
take my stuff
sure no richard jefferson is a total bro
he is the person i am down here with in
the bubble because he is just the most
like like like he's great and he's been
great in this environment um
but because he is a mischievous streak
he will definitely
employ it and the producers know that
waving that red
you know cape in front of him of saying
you know actually this will throw the
segment off
that's that's just trouble so are you
there were you next to him when he hit
send on giannis being a pippen
did were you there for that one rachel i
was not that was a phone call i was like
wait
what what are you doing oh my gosh
yeah yeah sometimes sometimes it happens
you know but again
here's the thing and you know this you
know so much in your chair
the worst thing is having a former
player who is afraid to say anything
i don't want people manufacturing tv
like that's crappy and everybody knows
it you can see right through it
but the players who feel and i respect
this but they're just
maybe not cut out for television who
feel like it's disloyal in some way to
talk honestly
about guys they know or teams that they
have left behind or hey it's a league
it's a code or whatever
that's great but then you probably
shouldn't be on tv right so i i do
really
enjoy when people when it's genuine i
don't want the manufacturer stuff but
when it's genuine i want i want those
guys to speak their mind and sometimes
take things off the rails and
and like if you're supposed to be doing
a segment about the nba finals and since
i'm talking about pizza
that's right i guess that's how we're
gonna go full that's how we're gonna
finish up full
circle rachel i feel i feel like this
could be a short series i'm not
you know you know i'm just getting the
sense this could be a short series
so if you want us to send you something
to eat
some food i think we got to get it in
now based on the strict protocols that i
had no idea that existed on pizza
pizza cutters uh which by the way
there's probably 90 of them
in one spot that's supposed to look like
italy and epcot
literally probably like two miles from
here so
what do you need what do you want like
what do you want no no i i don't like
again something could get hung up here
you know every package that comes in has
to get sprayed down in bleach and all
that stuff
i just when i get back to la uh we need
to we need to have like a group
like really good italian meal so that so
that i can wash the cardboard box food
out of my system all right rachel that's
a done deal um
thanks for the call appreciate it have a
good have a good rest of the stay in the
bubble
um i i i hope it's a short series for
you so you can get home
but i know that uh you're enjoying um
you know all the nba action so i
appreciate the call absolutely
i'll talk to you guys soon you guys
that's rachel nichols
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here